Big Time manager in the music industry
managers core day managing turbo who
else you manage tell me Genesis okay
Tommy Genesis a couple other um
a couple other development so how did
you get started in the music industry
because you're from Boston right yeah
from New Bedford Massachusetts man
um it's like 40 minutes south of Boston
um I had a mutual friend her name is
Suzette James
um she was living in Miami at the time I
was going to school in Florida
and we had a mutual friend of white Club
John ah yeah yeah so why come out of
concert down in Miami
I came down from Daytona Beach
to kick it with Susie on her college
campus Lynn University at the time it's
in Boca Raton Florida we went down to
watch cloud from Miami at the Fillmore
me and him just connected backstage we
like just
you know he's he was just cool as [__]
and he took a genuine interest to me I
was at school at the time I was playing
scholarship basketball so I wasn't even
in the music industry
St Andrews University
no but through cooking University at
this time in Daytona Beach so you were
going to school in Florida yeah yeah
yeah I was playing scholarship
basketball that's great so you ended up
meeting why clef just being straight
through her yeah he just [__] with you
and then from there from then what
happens with Wyclef I went back to
school this is like my
sophomore year right
um we just stayed in touch unfortunately
he was running for president in Haiti oh
I remember that yeah I forgot he did
that yeah bro what year was that
so
um he lost right he dropped out he got
shot and he was just like I'm good how
do I not remember Wyclef getting shot
trying to assessing him like the
president
you know it wasn't really that important
they tried to kill white clef well I
mean that's important but like
what the [__] yeah they should attempt
on one of the members of the Fugees and
the other guy
is it informant
maybe there's some lineage between the
two who knows did Pros set why clef on
numbers
[Laughter]
anyway so continue he was running for
president at the time yeah he was one of
the president at the time and um he was
just using me as like
his young eyes and ears for the
landscape where music was at because
even though he was in politics like it's
like he's still he's still a musician
and he was out of his deal with Sony you
know he had that song with um Akon and
Lil Wayne that was a smash
I'ma tell you like who told me cash
rules everything around me so yeah the
sweetest girl the sweetest girl
Swedish girls yes sweetest girl
yeah yeah it was the last one yeah I
remember
so like he had that record in like this
is like two years later when I met him
and he was just like this is one like it
was cool to be independent remember like
YouTube like took over TV and was the
Forefront in the centerpiece of all
kinds I feel like right now you're
really it's really like the when it's
cool to be independent though right now
for real everybody wants to be Indy you
get it out right now the labels on the
dsps they're like squeezing the juice
out of like episode on distro kid
you're paying for your own ads like how
are you gonna get in the playlist where
you get visibility for the first 24 to
48 hours playlist actually work after
that it's just visibility but visibility
is everything
awareness I think the Russell's done a
good job getting on playlists that's one
guy Russ Toon Core you know tell me what
what's the irony between both of those
names you just mentioned I know a few
guys who are doing very well together on
distro kid and on
but if you look at if you just look at
again I'm gonna use this word well I
don't want to get well we'll get to all
this but okay why clef 2010 2012. this
is what like
being independent was like cool like you
had like you know Funk Volume you have
okay yes
Strange Music was in the double XL like
it was you could be independent at the
chance was like Acid Rap Chance that was
that right Macklemore both him and
chance were independent-ish yeah even
Mac Miller like was Rostrum with like
that's independent like Boston was
Independence yeah they were at the time
you know but in any case um
I was just like putting clef on to like
what was happening at that time right
like J Cole was like
you know it's like Friday Night Lights
game all right mixtapes you know what
I'm saying like section 80 Kendrick and
[__] so I was just keeping them privy to
like who was popping and what was going
on and um
but by the time like my senior year came
around like I've been playing ball my
whole life and at a high level I just
got like burnt down tired of it stopped
being fun because it became a business
to me so I reached out the collapse I
was like
yo
I want to be in the music industry right
you know would you want to be like my
Aunt R I'm like yeah that's like I was
certainly consultant in the music
consultant in a r kind of fits the exact
description of what that is and he's
like okay don't call me when you
graduate I'm like dude I'm in college
like I can go pray play a pro overseas
I have a degree and it's like you're
like that's my like stamp of reassurance
when I get out of college like call me
when you graduate I'm like I graduated
today I quit yeah bro so I [__] I did
I mean I I graduated I just I went out
to New York to his crib
we chopped it up and kicked it more and
then I just started making back and
forth trips from like Massachusetts to
New York just getting in the studio with
him he was working at Daddy's house
um were you at uh I saw the only time I
saw Wyclef live
was randomly at South by Southwest in
like
2014. I didn't go with him I remember
that but I didn't go he was just on
stage with a guitar Schoolboy Q opened
and it was [__] gnarly it was like
why clef with a guitar and like a
basement in Austin just yeah no he's an
incredible performer he plays every
instrument he's a beast man well um but
you're not I mean in short form that was
kind of how like I got him was just like
I got him a clef I I was like
once I was working with him I was just
bringing in all of the people who were
like my peers who I was a fan of right
but they're fans of Wycliffe right so
because I'm their peer and I'm young and
I'm able to bring them in studio with
clef and put them on records and curate
videos and all types of [__] like
they're looking at me like I'm lit
because they're like this is a legend
and like this is the guy who's next to
him Ace and he relied on me to do that
and he gave me fortunately he gave me
his platform in the green light to be
able to just speak on his behalf and
carry anything around him that I thought
was dope useful and what was in because
he was a little disconnected from me so
I built a lot of my relationships from
originally utilizing clubs like this in
my positioning around him
um but then those relationships as time
would pass like I continue to add value
to them and they became a relationship
my own